[Music]
foreign
champions of this realm can do nothing
to stop us
you are very menacing I just want you to
know that
[Music]
a lot has changed in the last few years
a wizard gave me superpowers
and then everybody got super powers
all right here's the situation
the daughters of Atlas are coming to
hunt us
children is told the power of the Gods
you ripped it from our father's core
okay I feel like maybe I should be
writing all this down
your world will not survive this
you want these Powers come get them hey
Khaleesi
we have one job to do we save the world
I don't know how we fight powers like
this
I can't do this take my powers back you
came to me so you would take them back
right
I spent the Millennia
searching for worth a champion
exactly what must be done
Billy what are you doing I have to do
this we end this now
we do
start in front of platinum nowhere
foreign